yeah Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas  aren't planning for babies just yet it  was important to step into this new  chapter a source tells ET that the  couple who tied the knot in multiple  ceremonies last December do want kids  eventually but they haven't been putting  pressure on expanding the fam the source  says it's not a priority at the moment  as the two are choosing to focus on  their marriage traveling together and  their respective careers having Nick  with me I've never done this with  someone with me  you know it's just all really new and  amazing both Priyanka and Nick are  extremely busy especially since the  Jonas Brothers are reunited and are  gearing up for tour quote the couple is  conscious of how much time the tour  takes up it's obviously been oral when  the source adds the pair is okay with  when it happens it happens and it will  be a blessing knowing that whatever  happens you're not even alone and  there's such a beauty to that